- Hello?
- Sup.
- Welcome to my car.
You're now virtual passengers.
Today, Steven, we're doing savory pie.
An episode I'm very excited to do,
which is why I'm in the car
picking up the pies to bring to you guys.
(Steven claps)
- All right!
Well, today on Worth It,
we're gonna be trying three savory pies
at three drastically
different price points
to find out which one is the most worth it
at its price.
- A savory pie is like a chicken pot pie.
We're also talking about
small handheld pies.
- And in some parts of the world,
when they say pie, they mean 3.141592...
Something, something-
- Keep going, keep going.
- Something, something.
- Pot pie is one of my favorite foods.
- And when you got the flaky crust-
- Oh!
- That buttery crust.
- Our first pie is going to
be of the handheld variety.
We're seeing Winston at
his food truck, Saraba,
which specializes in
Belizean Garifuna cuisine.
And we're having his panades.
(relaxing music)
- My name is Winston Miranda
from Saraba Garifuna Cuisine.
My food is typically from my mom's culture
which is the Garifuna people.
My ancestors, they came
from a part of South Africa,
Sierra Leone, and they
migrated to Saint Vincent.
And from Saint Vincent
they went to Honduras,
from Honduras they went to Belize.
Our food is very unique.
We have one that we call the hudut,
which is like a staple food that
we eat every day.
The fisherman will go to the sea
and bring the fish in,
and then we fry it, we'll
season the coconut milk
and get a flavor off of it,
and add the fish to it,
and boil some plantain.
And then they will mash it
so you can get it real smooth,
and put it like a ball,
and then you'll eat it
with the coconut milk.
The panades is like a appetizer.
Most Americans call it
like, American Hot Pockets.
And it can be eaten any time of the day,
early in the morning,
late at night, mid-day.
We take the masa, and
then we use the achiote.
In Belize they call it
recado, it's a red paste.
And the masa will turn from white to red.
And then people will say,
"Oh yeah, he's making authentic panades."
Just by the color when people look at it.
You can do it with fish,
you can do it with chicken,
and you can do it with beans.
Flatten it up, and then we fry it.
There's a habanero onion sauce.
I can make it spicy and
I can make it non-spicy.
Late at night when I'm doing like clubs
and all that stuff, people are drunk,
so they want the hot, hot one,
the hot habanero sauce.
So, that'll wake them up.
Saraba means "wake up".
- [Andrew] Oh.
- Yeah.
That's what it means, "wake up".
(cash register rings)
- Ooh.
The smell is really good.
It kind of smells like Fritos.
- Oh, whoa!
- [Andrew] Is this the shape you think of
when you think of pie?
- When I think about pie, I think autumn,
I think leaves.
Pumpkin pie, that's the classic pie.
I love how the outside
looks like the crust
of a really good pizza.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
(lighthearted music)
- Mm.
- It's interesting how tightly
the seafood is wrapped.
It's like tightly wound around the dough,
which I really like.
- Yeah, and then you just have like
the thin crust around the outside.
- Kind of like a fish?
- Like a stegosaurus.
Oh, sure, like a fish.
(chuckling)
- I want onion relish.
- Yeah, let's go onion relish.
- Mm.
- Oh, yeah!
- Yeah.
- That's the stuff.
- It's perfect.
- Okay.
- Just a nice vinegar bath
goin across that thing.
- Oh man!
It's so good.
- Oh yeah!
Ooh.
- [Steven] Oh, wow!
- And a little spicy.
- Man, flavor combinations.
- It tastes very similar to
squeezing lime on a taco.
- You know that, super satisfying
power washing videos?
- Yeah.
- I don't know why, but I
was just reminded of those.
- No, that totally makes sense.
It's like when a liquid is sharp.
When I first opened
the box I was like wow,
you get a lot of these.
Now I'm like, should've doubled it.
- I'm gonna do one more.
I'm going to be talking
about the onion sauce
until the day I die.
- I thought it was a mistake how much
onion stuff we got, actually.
But it was so good, I was
shoveling it into my mouth.
I'm ready for a savory pie fact.
- [Steven] Savory pie fact!
- The fist known usage of "sweetie pie"
dates from 1928.
- 1928?
That seems pretty late for "sweetie pie".
That would've been revolutionary.
Like, sweetie pie, whoa.
I'm more of a savory pie myself,
but you can call me a sweetie pie.
- Sweetie pie is something
that I call my cat, actually.
- Yeah?
Is he a little sweetie pie?
- He is a little sweetie pie.
- Does he do that thing where he like,
stops there next to you,
drop kinda like on his belly
and roll around?
What is that about?
Like, what does that mean by the way?
- It means that they are a sweetie pie.
- Oh, okay, got it.
- For our next savory pie
we're visiting Natalia at WOODSPOON
to try her Brazilian chicken pot pie.
We're also going to have
their house-made sangria.
(lighthearted music)
- WOODSPOON serve a traditional
food from Minas Gerais,
where I'm from.
We have a lot to offer
in terms of our culinary.
We are very simple, but
our flavor very unique.
I was born and raised in Brazil.
When I got here, of course,
it was very hard for me
because not speak any English at all.
You know, I didn't understand
why you go to the beach
with an outfit on, you know?
Why can't you get on a bus in a bikini?
Why you don't go and get
fresh eggs from somewhere,
or there was fresh
chicken from some places.
The way we would do in Brazil
is a little different than here,
because you have the privilege to buy
just a particular type of meat.
There my mom would make a whole chicken.
Here, I was able to buy chicken thigh.
We have to clean them one by one,
removing all the fats,
unnecessary pieces that is there
to make sure it's nice and clean.
I save the broth and I use
the fat that stays above
to make the roux.
Add the heart of palm, corn, olives.
A heart of palm is a heart of a palm tree,
and it is a particular one.
In Brazil, you can actually get, like,
they can be this tall, this big.
But here, we only get the
very small parts of it.
Corn, we had it everywhere in the backyard
where we planted it ourselves.
Olives, because you
know, we are Portuguese.
Brazil is a country with
all countries in it.
You know, people get surprised how we have
the biggest Japanese
community in the world
is in Brazil.
There is more Lebanese in
Brazil than in Lebanon.
Like, we have in my town
in Minas, a lot of Chinese.
Because the agriculture, the farming.
We have stroganoff, a German dish.
We have all these incredible
cultures and gastronomy in Brazil
that I felt like opening WOODSPOON
would give me an opportunity to
show a little bit more
what Brazil can offer.
I just wanted people to know Brazil
not just the postcard,
but also into those little cultures
that it's so rich, and so
real, and so important.
This is my home.
Whatever we can do for people
to educate themselves through food.
I believe food is a bridge
that connects us all,
and this is mine.
- Okay, fellas.
Welcome to the next pie.
- I'm ready.
- We have two house-made sangrias.
- The red sangria we have citruses,
we have black pepper, we have cinnamon,
and a little bit of a touch of a secret.
And then we have in the white one,
a base of passion fruit.
- Passion fruit Chardonnay.
- You know what it is?
It's an in between color.
- Look at that.
- Those are the best colors.
Some lights it's one
thing, others it's another.
- Cheers.
(lighthearted music)
- Oh my God.
- Geez Louise.
- That should be illegal.
Okay, now just a little of the red.
- Holy!
- Whoa!
- Smokes.
This is the best sangria I've ever had.
- So, check out this pie, that spoon.
- Oh!
I didn't even see the spoon.
- Oh.
- Oh my goodness.
(chuckling)
- Oh!
- That's perfect.
That is-
- That is really perfect.
Buttery chicken.
I was also a little bit surprised
that there were olives in this pot pie,
but it doesn't taste overly olive-y.
- You know when you meet somebody
and you're just like, we're
gonna be best friends.
I've never met you before,
but the connection is
there, the chemistry,
like something about you
and me, we just get along.
And I have never met this
chicken pot pie before,
but I already know, I already know you.
- It's like an old baseball mitt.
It has this like, supple familiarity.
- Yes, supple.
- Do you want us to eat the sauce?
- Wait, sauce?
What sauce?
- This green sauce on the side.
- Oh, I put that in the salad.
- The thick sauce?
- The thick sauce.
- You put the thick sauce in the salad?
(laughing)
- I didn't know!
- That's so American of you.
You see that thick
dairy and you're like...
That's gotta go on a salad.
(laughing)
Oh!
- That reminds me of the sangria
that we just had like three minutes ago.
- Yes, it does.
It's smooth but also a little spicy.
- I really thought that
the onion sauce from Saraba
was gonna be the last thing
that blew my mind today, but no.
(chuckling)
Pie the way, I slept very well last night.
- Yeah, rise and pie.
- Hey, roll us a pie fact.
(chuckling)
No, no, wait, that doesn't make sense.
Bake us a...
I was thinking about the crust.
Bake us a pie fact.
- It's estimated that Australia consumes
270 million meat pies every year,
approximately 12 per person.
- You're telling me every Australian
is eating one meat pie
every month of the year.
- In comparison, New Zealand only consumes
66 million meat pies per year,
but with their much smaller population,
that equates to 15 pies
per person every year.
- What?
- Oh!
15 per year for the Kiwis.
- Why are they called Kiwis?
We should be calling them Pie-e's.
(laughing)
- Funny that we're mentioning
Australian savory pies
because the next pie is actually inspired-
- In-pie-red?
- By Australian savory pie.
We're seeing Chef Ryan at Chi Spacca.
We're gonna be trying
their bone marrow pie.
(lighthearted music)
- Chi Spacca has been described
as a "meat speakeasy" by Jonathan Gold.
This dish represents trying to take
a classic meat dish,
an Australian meat pie,
and really trying to do it
the best of its possibilities.
So, first step is making a veal stock.
Roasted veal bones, simmering
for about 6 to 8 hours.
We cut up beef cheek into little pieces,
and then we salt them
and let it sit overnight.
That allows for the salt
to actually penetrate
the meat itself.
When you have a stew or a braised meat
and the meat isn't seasoned
ahead of time, you can tell.
The meat is just being
covered up by a salty liquid.
You get a nice caramelization
on the outside of it.
And heavy caramelization.
We then take that out of the
pan and add cipollini onions.
Cipollini, I mean, it really just means
"little onion" in Italian.
And button mushrooms with a
little bit of thyme and garlic.
So we want to get the same
color on those vegetables
that we do on the meat.
The reason we do that separate is because
they cook at different
temperatures and different speeds.
We de-glaze with the fortified veal stock.
Bring the meat in and let the meat cook
for about 2 hours or so.
Beef cheek is something
that most people don't use,
but it works amazing
because you're braising it
and beef cheek has a
lot of connective tissue
that breaks down and makes it so that
you have this beautiful
mouthfeel to the sauce,
and the meat itself is tender.
We put the vegetables
in for the last hour.
If we put the vegetables
in the very beginning,
they would just dissolve.
Roll out just a savory pie dough.
In the top pie we cut a little circle
so that the bone marrow
actually can fit through.
We sell them both baked off,
like ready to go to eat,
or you can take it home and bake it.
We've actually probably sold more raw pies
than we have cooked pies.
We actually are happy about that,
because when you bake a pie,
you want to eat it right away.
The texture from the bone marrow,
the fattiness of the bone
marrow with the stew,
it almost sounds like
it can be overwhelming,
you know, kind of, why do you need that?
People call bone marrow "meat butter".
It adds this unctuous texture.
It's really, really delicious.
(cash register ding)
- Look at this pie!
- There's something strange yet beautiful
about a bone protruding from crust.
- You know what it looks like, right?
- It looks like some Flintstones (bleep).
- Oh, I was gonna say it
looks like a bellybutton.
(laughing)
- The fact that you bring this one home
and heat it up so your own house
can get filled with that aroma.
- Oh my.
All right, let's dig in.
Oh my God.
What?
Why is it so gooey?
I can't wait.
- Come on!
(laughing)
Yes!
- Woo!
I am so glad I am not at Chi Spacca
right now eating this.
The noises coming out of my mouth-
- We'd be causing a scene.
- Let's do bone marrow.
So, the last two pies that we had
were accompanied by some
of the greatest sauces.
This one, the sauce comes
right in the middle,
and you just scoop it out.
- Whoa.
- Get outta here!
- Bathe my mouth.
- I never thought that a beef stew
would need to add more
soft moistness to it.
It's out of this world.
- The last thing I want
to say about this...
Look at that meat.
- Well, fellas.
Time to say pie pie for now.
- I became a pie today,
and it's a good life.
- Steven, which savory pie was the most
worth it to you at its price?
- All these pies I think tied for me,
so I had to give it to the best sauce.
My Worth It winner, I'm
going with Saraba today.
The onion sauce?
Holy smokes.
What about you?
- Gosh, I love pie.
Chi Spacca, I think most high end food
is not as good taken away
as it would be eaten in the restaurant,
but that pie I think is
a great exactly of one
that's maybe even better eaten at home.
My Worth It winner goes to WOODSPOON.
I love chicken pot pie.
That pot pie was perfect, and I loved it.
- Adam, who's your Worth It winner?
- [Adam] WOODSPOON.
- By the way, what pants
are you wearing right now?
'Cause I'm wearing sweatpants because
I knew this would be a heavy pie day, so.
- Yeah, I'm wearing
shorts with a drawstring,
and it is not tied.
(catchy music)
♪ Worth It ♪